quoi là messieurs bonsoir j'ai dans la
main une petite fortune sont pourtant
que des pièces d'usagé courant que
nombre d'entre vous possède chez eux les
anciennes pièces de cinq francs de 10
francs et 50 francs et bien partir de
demain
ces pièces cesseront d'avoir cours légal
elles sont ce que l'on appelle des mots
dénis démonétisé ça veut dire que vous
ne pourrez plus payer vos achats avec
elle pourrait quand même les échanger
auprès de la banque de france et les
comptables du trésor mais je ne vous le
conseille pas et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi cette pièce de 5 francs que
vous voyez ici avec un petit peu
d'argent à l'intérieur une pièce qui a
été frappé entre 59 et 69
cette pièce là vaudra demain auprès de
n'importe quel marchand d'argent 45
francs cette pièce de 10 francs
maintenant je ne compte pas mes
différentes a frappé entre 64 et 73 vaut
dix fois plus aujourd'hui 100 francs et
puis sa grande soeur de 50 francs qui
étaient frappées elles entre 74 et 79 en
vaut aujourd'hui 121 temps une manière
de petit miracle que nous démontre très
logiquement philippe sassier pipe que
nous allons donc rejoindre pour essayer
de comprendre ce qui a pu se passer et
ce qui se va se passer pauvres au prix
que vous veniez d'indiquer les français
procèdent pour environ 18 milliards de
francs de ses pièces dans leur bas de
laine et c'est effectivement un miracle
que l'on peut expliquer cette pièce de 5
francs contient 10 grammes d'argent pur
la pièce de 10 francs on contient 22 et
celle de 50 francs 25 grammes et comme
un gramme d'argent ou 4 francs 50 à peu
près le prix d'une demi-livre de beurre
faites le calcul vous même et vous
parvenez aux chiffres indiqués par
patrick poivre d'arvor
alors que s'est-il passé il y eu d'abord
la fantastique flambé de l'argent du
cours de ce métal ont été multipliés par
7 entre 1978 et 1979
dans un premier temps l'état a cessé de
frapper ces pièces qui lui coûtait trop
cher
dans un deuxième temps il les retire de
la circulation et seules le cours de
l'argent métal fixera désormais la
valeur de la pièce il faut dire qu'une
pièce en circulation ne peut pas être
bon
dû au dessus de sa valeur faciale c'est
à dire la valeur qui est inscrite 2 etc
est fixé par l'état la loi interdit
également de la fondre pour récupérer le
métal qu'elle contient et un fructueux
trafic s'était instaurée entre la france
et la suisse
il suffisait d'aller en suisse avec une
pièce de 5 francs français pour la
revendre dix fois plus chères et
certains faisait le voyage avec des sacs
et des valises mais attention la vente
de ces pièces va être désormais soumises
aux 6 % de taxes sur les métaux précieux
en effet nous avons acheté ses prix et
ses pièces à imprimer amputé de 6 %
comme toutes les pièces modernes
alors aujourd'hui j'ai eu beaucoup
d'animations sur ces monnaies
d'animation pas encore nous avons eu
énormément de coups de téléphone pour
nous demander les conditions mais nous
pensons que demain matin dès l'ouverture
des ti chez beaucoup de gens vont se
présenter avec sacs et valises comme
nous l'avons déjà connu pour d'autres
pièces on s'attend à rejouer
alors quels conseils donner à ceux aux
épargnants qui ont de ces pièces dans
leur tirelire
eh bien je crois qu'on peut leur donner
le conseil de ne pas se précipiter à nos
clichés en effet maintenant ces pièces
ont un cours déterminé par le cours du
métal ils ne risquent rien alors ne pas
créer de panique
peut-être pour ne pas influencer
également le courant général du marché
de l'argent et puis pour ne pas créer ce
que nous avons connu sur l'or il ya
quelques mois qu'il est profitable pour
personne mais alors donc pour ne pas
vous tannique et je rappelle crédit donc
des pièces d'argent les anciennes pièces
de 10 francs de 50 francs et de 5 francs
et que cela ne touche pas
malheureusement ces petites pièces jonas
t de 10 francs que vous connaissez
actuellement qui elles ne prennent pas
un sou de plus deuxième sujet de
conversation qui a beaucoup animé les
cafés les chaumières ce matin le
gigantesque carambolage de l'auto de
l'ouest y bière et bien cela a commencé
aujourd'hui à l'heure du déjeuner sur la
même autoroute peu après la sortie du
tunnel de saint cloud dans le sens paris
province
mais là il n'y avait pas de brouillard
est en revanche beaucoup de camions jour
dans le domaine de ce qu'on appelle les
faits divers et qui alimente de nombreux
sujets de polémique à l'intérieur même
des familles
il ya les drames provoqués par
l'autodéfense terme impropre d'ailleurs
pour la dernière affaire du genre celle
de vitry près de paris le gardien d'une
cité de hlm a tiré samedi sur un jeune
algérien il l'a tué il a été aujourd'hui
inculpé le reportage de pierre forgues
parce que les jeunes de la cité des
montagnards chahuté comme presque tous
les soirs dans les banlieues tristes et
les cités où l'on s'ennuie
parce que c'est vrai dans ces banlieues
les bonnes gens ont peur passée une
certaine heure samedi soir les deux
univers celui de la peur et celui
l'ennui se sont rencontrés un locataire
agacés ou énervés par le bruit va
chercher le gardien d'immeuble auquel sa
femme temps une carabine
un coup de feu claque il est fatal pour
abdelkader lahrech 15 ans
sortie d'un café l'élastine 400 coups
bas les pauvres c'est un gars de cet
appel est une chose c'est par ce soir
face à l'ambitieux elle est un vieux que
l'habitude c'est là mon fils et les
commentaires ont regardé comme tout le
monde
deux autres des fois il nous rend des
services qu'on a besoin d'un local de la
callune j'ouvre la porte puis après nous
leur ferme et envoyé travailler là il
était gentil rigole avec tout ça je le
ferai bien poing par derrière
il fait j'ai pas fait des menaces dans
la r et comment vous expliquez ça vous
dit il était gentil et puis tout d'un
coup comme ça ils se grattent quoi moi
je dis ça au critt là comme ça soit
disons que c'est sa femme qui consiste à
tirer celle qui va passer cuisine
et michel baylet 34 ans a tiré violence
ennuis psychose de peur parfois
peut-être aussi amplifié par les médias
et la télévision elle même on peut
difficilement expliquer ce geste vers
les jeunes là c'est ce qu'on pourra
donner voulu faire le jeu comment il a
voulu faire justice soi même
aujourd'hui une quinzaine de jeunes gens
ont dévasté la loge du gardien de cet
immeuble et quant aux causes profondes
du lourd climat qui règne dans la cité
des montagnards eh bien nous proposons
de les exposer plus longuement
prochainement au terme d'une enquête
effectuée en profondeur sur place
quatrième thème de conversations
inspirés de l'actualité d'hier ce que je
vous disais à propos d'une importante
découverte médical pour traiter l'asthme
douloureuse maladie s'il en est mais en
fait ce n'est pas avant six ou sept ans
que la thérapeutique pourra être
utilisée martin arogno mais d'ores et
déjà on en connaît les cno alors c'est
une découverte importante mais sans
application immédiate et il ne faut pas
rêver trop vite c'est sûr je vais
essayer d'être clair depuis longtemps
c'est ce que c'est que l'asthme c'est
une contraction anormale des bronches
d'un seul coup on étouffe les bronches
sur a36 c'est l'étouffement
caractéristiques et qui gène mutant
bonjour la trouve hélas supprimés parce
que cette construction ne se fait pas
tout seul comme vous imaginez où on
connaissait un certain nombre de
substances qui s'appelle des médiateurs
et qui provoquait cette contraction
on les avait isolé est l'une des
substances dont on a parlé hier les
connais depuis 40 ans mais ne suffit pas
de l'avoir isolé pour pouvoir trouver la
clé du mécanisme riel leucotriènes une
deuxième substance qui agit par voie
générale dans les plaquettes sanguines
ces petites cellules qui ressemblent à
des globules rouges et qui sont
responsables de la coagulation contient
aussi les médiateurs alors ce qui s'est
passé c'est que après 40 ans de
recherche d'un caillou huit ans dans
l'autre on a fini par comprendre la
structure et en faire la synthèse c'est
à dire que maintenant grâce à des
équipes américaines suédoise et dans les
deux cas française chercheurs de
strasbourg était aux états unis un
chercheur du cnrs était aux états unis
pour le 4ème et c'est une équipe
française d'auteurs benveniste de
l'inserm qui a trouvé la lauzière
bon maintenant on
louis de molécules chimiques avec
lesquels on peut bricoler alors ce que
l'on peut faire c'est espérer trouver
des substances analogue qui sont en
compétition et qui bloque six substances
là et leur action ou bien trouver un
moyen de bloquer la synthèse de ces
substances si les nantais qui provoque
la contraction des alors ce sera
certainement pas avant plusieurs années
parce que pour l'instant on a trouvé le
mécanisme de l'asthme
maintenant il faut trouver lentilles
mécanismes de la vie lorsqu'on a
retrouvé une molécule concurrentes si
vous voulez il faudra l'essayer de
manière clinique avec des
expérimentations animales de toxicologie
tout ceci prend un grand temps on
l'évalué dans le meilleur des cas à cinq
à sept ans mais c'est tout de même un
grand espoir il ya des actions
concertées notamment en france entre
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et organise
recherche et je crois que maintenant ça
peut être assez à grands pas et dieu
sait s'ils n'ont été les sculptures qui
nous écoutent peut être touché par la
wii j'ai retenu deux chiffres
aujourd'hui un million et demi d'enfants
asthmatiques et 7 millions de personnes
allergiques elle aussi économique et
politique maintenant le bord ces
prévisions pessimistes de l' ocde pour
l'ensemble de l'occident
l'organisation prédit maintenant une
croissance zéro pour l'année en cours en
fait un chiffre d'augmentation du pnb le
produit national brut de 0 3% dans
chaque pays au mieux l'eau ces deux
parlent aussi de 20 millions de
personnes frappées par le chômage à la
fin de l'année dans les 24 pays qui la
composent
les chiffres de l'inflation ne sont
guère encourageants non plus et c'est
sans doute ce qui a conduit le premier
ministre qui s'exprimait aujourd'hui
devant l'association des amis de la
république française a lancé un appel
sans ambiguïté vous allez le voir à la
fois aux salariés et aux chefs
d'entreprise raymond barre que nous
écoutons maintenant
le gouvernement par ailleurs n'a pas
l'intention de porter atteinte
aujourd'hui pas plus qu'hier à la
politique conventionnelle en matière de
rémunération mais les chefs d'entreprise
doivent savoir qu au cas où leur
politique des salaires excéderait ou
même absorberait entièrement les gains
de productivité ils ne pourront compter
ni sur de plus en plus facilité de
crédit ni sur des mesures
protectionnistes niche sur une
dépréciation du franc
telle est la règle du jeu du régime de
liberté et de responsabilité qu'ils
réclament d'ailleurs à bon droit la
lutte contre l'inflation est enfin de la
responsabilité des travailleurs le
maintien du pouvoir d'achat devient dans
les circonstances actuelles un objectif
de plus en plus ambitieux mais la
vigueur de nos entreprises la très forte
productivité et le potentiel de progrès
de l'économie française me conduise à
penser que cet objectif peut être
réalisé à condition que les travailleurs
français sachent écarté comme ils l'ont
fait jusqu'ici revendications excessives
et surenchères néfastes le maintien du
pouvoir d'achat des français
despentes avant tout d'un effort
collectif des français matière politique
maintenant ce sondage du journal elle
trois français sur quatre estiment que
les femmes des candidats à l'elysée
doivent participer activement à la
campagne présidentielle mais la plupart
des français ne croient pas à l'arrivée
d'une femme à l'elysée avant l'an 2000
je ne vous donnerai pas en vous disant
que anne aymone giscard d'estaing
apparaît comme l'épousé idéale d'un
candidat à l'elysée suivi par michel
rocard que pour cent personnes non ou
presque ne connaît bernadette chirac
danielle mitterrand et liliane marché je
vous rappelle quand même que sont les
maris qui seront peut-être candidat 80
un candidat en voici un peu connue
encore mais déjà très lu roger garaudy
un ancien du pc qui a d'ores et déjà
annoncé son intention de se jeter dans
la bataille de 80
février soixante dix il y a dix ans
presque jour pour jour un dernier
discours et roger garaudy s'en va il
rompt avec 37 ans de parti communiste ce
qu'ils éloignent lui l'ancien stalinien
de la tête aux pieds comme il dit c'est
la ligne choisie par son parti après 68
trop social démocrate dit il le parti
s'intègre au modèle de croissance
capitaliste écrivain philosophe garaudy
s'interroge il écrit beaucoup sur la
politique sur dieu sur la danse dix ans
de réflexion pour aboutir à la paix
l'eau vivants un livre mais aussi le
sigle de sa campagne
ancien député ancien sénateur roger
garaudy est donc candidat à la
présidence son programme faire une
politique en autorisant le des paroles
assez bas depuis quelques années et ses
problèmes non dépend de mon premier
notre marche en avant les problèmes de
la croissance du modèle de croissance
les problèmes du nucléaire qu'il soit
civil ou militaire
et il ne s'agit pas seulement de faire
un catalogue de revendications comme le
sont d'ordinaire les programmes
politiques mais à travers chacune des
revendications nous entendons défendre
préparer un changement fondamental des
rapports sociaux mais qui allez vous
gêner le plus la gauche les écologistes
et votre entreprise n'est ce pas diviser
encore plus l'opposition
je vous avoue que je ne me suis pas posé
le problème car les quatre grands partis
ont choisi également ce modèle de
croissance se nucléaire civil et
militaire c'est-à-dire tout ce qui nous
conduit à la mort par conséquent je n'ai
pas à choisir entre de telles formations
et lettres que je reçois de comités prêt
à soutenir une telle action au monde que
nous sommes quelques millions de
marginaux de ce genre en france
les marginaux et puis un autre candidat
jean marie le pen a dénoncé aujourd'hui
le caractère politique des poursuites
engagées contre lui pour discrimination
raciale
on lui reproche et affiche un million de
chômeurs c'est un mignoni 1001 en trop
la france et les français d'abord
politique étrangère tito rien 9 le
dernier bulletin médical par le même
d'un léger mieux
marshall c'est aujourd'hui assis dans
son lit
les otages de teyran rien de vraiment
neuf non plus à de multiples reprises la
maison blanche a démenti que ce soit
rencontré à paris hamilton jordan qui le
secrétaire général de la maison blanche
et ce avec votre ad ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères à téhéran le
président bani sadr a été nommé par
l'ayatollah khomeiny qui jusqu'àlors en
avait la fonction commandant en chef des
forces armées
et puis canada la victoire attendue de
pierre elliott trudeau ce qu'on
n'attendait pas revanche c'est le
triomphe la majorité absolue pour les
libéraux 146 débuter contre 103 pour les
conservateurs pierre elliott trudeau a
donc désormais les mains libres
ses premières paroles de vainqueur
finalement finalement je voudrais vous
dire que dans les tâches qui nous
attendent
j'aurai besoin personnellement de la vie
de chacun d'entre vous il y à des tâches
immenses à faire pendant cette décennie
non seulement pour faire du canada un
pays fort
le discours de remerciement de monsieur
trudeau est d'une banalité étudié à
l'image de la campagne électorale sans
éclat qui l'a mené comme si son unique
souci était de ne pas bousculer les
lecteurs et sa devise pas devin
l'événement lui a donné raison
très tôt hier soir à peine les bureaux
de vote fermés on savait qu'ils
emportaient il n'était pas 21h30 à
montréal que les libéraux atteignait la
majorité absolue de 142 voix sur 282
sièges et pierre elliott trudeau euro
devenait premier ministre après huit
mois seulement déclic au quartier
général de l'ancien ministre des
affaires interprovincial marc lalonde à
milliers profilant tribaux s'étaient
malgré ça sert sûrement mais sûrement
pas inattendu
les sondages avaient tout prévu
dans l'euphorie de la victoire les
difficulté s'estompe mais elle demeure
comme tout le monde
le canada connaît la crise économique
inflation chômage à quoi s'ajoutent des
grêles et pourtant le pays dispose de
grandes richesses il
vieille province québec ontario les plus
peuplées sont hautement industrialisés à
l'ouest l'alberta par exemple à elle de
fabuleuses ressources en pétrole où cela
ne fait qu'ajouter au malaise politique
ah si l'alberta souhaite plus
d'indépendance pour pouvoir être
maîtresse de disposer à sa guise de ses
ressources économiques
quant au québec c'est à l'indépendance
pure et simple qu'il aspire pour
préserver son identité culturelle
les grands vainqueurs du jour les
libéraux sont les plus farouches
adversaires du séparatisme québécois
je pense que la victoire aujourd'hui
voilà qui plaira pour
la volonté des québécois de maintenir le
lien fédéral
c'était le cas encore le printemps
dernier hommage mais alors qu'on peut en
faire pâlir nos grands partis ont 60 17
sièges sur 75
il semble qu'aujourd'hui nous allons
l'emporter 74 sièges sur 74 alors
le parti québécois au gouvernement du
québec que bien essayé de mettre en
doute notre légitimité
je ne pense pas que personne au québec
ou ailleurs
pour la ou à l'étranger l'espère qui
osera mettre en doute la légitimité
maintenant l'urss l'académicien sakharov
affirme avoir été molestés vendredi
dernier dans un poste de police
gorki bangui condamnation à mort d'un
gendre de bokassa qui avait administré
sur hors de son beau-père un poison un
bébé le fils d'un commandant de l'armée
de l'air qui lui même avait été exécuté
la veille de la naissance de l'enfant
liban toujours l'ami trahi tout un
secteur du château de beaufort s'est
effondré hier soir et puis afghanistan
une vive condamnation tout à l'heure à
rome des neuf ministres des affaires
étrangères qui ont lancé l'idée d'un
afghanistan neutre victor ramalho hier
les fans élément nouveau c'est que nous
avons décidé que le retrait des forces
soviétiques d'afghanistan était
l'objectif que nous poursuivons et qu'il
fallait nous allons explorer les voies
et les moyens pour le rendre possible
qu'à cet égard l'idée de rechercher une
formule plaçant l'afghanistan dans une
position de neutralité à l'écart de la
rivalité des grandes puissances
pourraient être une voix nous avons
décidé de mettre cette solution à
l'étude et quand nous l'aurons fait d'en
parler avec les différents états de la
région ainsi qu'avec nos amis et nos
alliés et vous pensez nous sommes sûrs
que ce principe de la neutralité de
l'afghanistan peu avancé être acceptée
même par les soviétiques
nous le verrons cette une suggestion ce
n'est pas encore une proposition c'est
une orientation et nous allons la creuse
et l'approfondir ce n'est pas un peu une
fuite en avant
écoutez
nous avons un objectif c'est de rétablir
les conditions qui permettent à la paix
de retrouver tous ses droits et des
propositions de ce type sont je crois de
celles qui peuvent y contribuer en tout
ça il n'y a pas de position commune en
ce qui concerne le cottage des jeux
olympiques et vous avions parlé du
premier jeu de la vie je ne crois pas
que il faille grossir ce problème ni
penser qu'il se situe au centre de la
crise internationale actuelle je crois
que tout le monde en est un peu d'accord
et nous avons convenu d'en reparler
d'ici quelques temps à la lumière de
l'évolution de la situation
voilà en effet une initiative qui
intervient la veille du délai fixé par
le plan carter pour mettre à exécution
sa menace de boycottage des jeux
olympiques si le 20 février avait il dit
les soviétiques n'ont pas quitté
l'afghanistan et bien nous n'irons pas
aux jeux olympiques
rien n'indique que moscou soit disposé à
faire plaisir à jimmy carter moscou n'a
même pas fait le petit geste que
certains espéraient aucune des unités de
l'armée soviétique stationnés en
afghanistan le 27 décembre n'a été
retiré du pays moscou fait la sourde
oreille à l'ultimatum du président
carter plus encore
tout se passe comme si l'état major
soviétique de kaboul estimait
insuffisants les moyens hôtels disposent
en afghanistan les avions antonov ont
débarqué ces dernières semaines la
relève des troupes d'intervention ils
ont également apporté des matériels des
matériels neufs
ce dont l'armée russe a besoin pour
lutter contre les rebelles avant il
semble en effet se confirmer que le
corps expéditionnaire soviétique se
heurtent à une résistence chaque jour
plus vive de la part des moudjahiddine
et de certains éléments de l'armée
afghane c'est ce qu'affirment les
responsables des mouvements islamiques
c'est aussi ce qui fait dire à certains
que l'armée de l'union soviétique
commence à réaliser en afghanistan
et puis deux dernières dépêches de
l'étranger une organisation basque
basque espagnol a lancé des menaces
contre les intérêts français dans cette
partie de l'espagne et en turquie
gouvernement a décidé de prolonger
l'état de siège de deux mois une autre
dernière dépêche 8 inculpation un
commissaire de police six inspecteurs et
un agent des douanes à la suite de
brutalité lors de l'interrogatoire de
trois personnes soupçonnées de trafic de
drogue ça s'est passé à strasbourg la
mort de firmin bauby l'yonne brooks
était vraiment l'une des plus belles
peut-être la plus belle figure sans
doute du monde du cirque français
et puis 80 mille emplois en l'an 2000
c'est ce qu'annonce pouvoir créer le
président du coc mais c'est peu dire le
commissariat à l'énergie solaire qui
fête aujourd'hui son deuxième
anniversaire c'est peu de dire il s'agit
d'une énergie en ébullition les idées
vous allez le voir avec georges leclercq
foisonnent en ce moment dans le monde du
solaire les idées foisonnent en effet
surtout depuis la célébration du jour du
soleil patronné par antenne 2 en juin
dernier
que ce soit dans l' architecture dans
l'énergie le mode de vie la recherche
partout des nouveautés arrivent mais
oublions pour une fois les photos puis
les éoliennes l'énergie des vagues et
prenons comme secteur l'habitat le plus
simple des secteurs l'habitat notre
habitait son besoin d'eau chaude avec
comme appareil solaire le capteur
solaire
regardez tout ce qu'on a inventé d'abord
avec cette maison
les capteurs cylindrique qui concentre
le soleil celui ci vient de lyon voici
des capteurs tube de télévision on
manquait plus que ça
celui ci au centre technique du bâtiment
sont orientables et suivent le cours la
course du soleil dans la journée mais un
capteur pose des gros problèmes de tuer
de robinet alors en voici un ou le
ballon d'eau chaude et directement à
l'intérieur de cette caisse orange pas
de murs à percer pour paul est posée ce
ballon à la cave au grenier deux tuyaux
et c'est fini voilà en quelque sorte
pour la première direction des idées
qu'ils soient zone dans le solaire
il y en a d'autres
il ya une deuxième direction pour lequel
nous ouvrons une voie nouvelle
c'est celle de la redécouverte de la
biomasse alors l'énergie verte en
quelques énergies vertes qui a servi
jusqu'au 19ème siècle à l'ensemble de
notre économie et toute l'industrie
fonctionner au bois jusque jusqu'à la
révolution
on redécouvre le bois on redécouvre la
paille on découvre le fumier les
fondamentalistes en recherche envisage
une simulation de l'hydrogène produit
par les plantes les arbres sont à la
mode bref il ya un foisonnement d'idées
vraiment absolument fantastique et qui
constituent cet ensemble de programmes
verts qui est à la fois immédiats
puisque nous pouvons dans les années qui
viennent doubler ou tripler notre
transformation de bois de chauffage de
paille est espéré pour l'an 2000 les
solutions sont pas nouvelles
malgré tout cela les prévisions sollers
et 5% l'an 2000
est ce assez pour être un rêve ou trop
peu pour un combat et puisque nous
sommes passionnés de sciences il faut
que je vous montre cette petite pièce
qui est tout à fait extraordinaire voilà
vous la voyez bien il faut regarder le
centre c'est-à-dire la plaquette sont
dans la plaquette brune c'est un
composant électronique est bien avec ce
circuit
la france est en train de brûler les
étapes pour rattraper son retard par
rapport aux pays étrangers dans cette
petite pièce brune
il y à l'équivalent de 70 mille
transistors alors qu'il ya six ans sur
la même pièce on en trouvait que 100 et
jusqu'à présent il faut dire que la
france dépendait essentiellement du
japon et de l'amérique pour certains de
ses composants électroniques les
athlètes français partent en guerre ils
veulent aller à moscou et ils l'ont dit
bien haut et bien fort au stade pierre
de coubertin le bien nommé
visiblement la tête français ne pense
pas que leurs comités olympiques
suffisent à les défendre
ils étaient 3000 tout à l'heure à
soutenir un comité d accueil mesure
c'est une idée de nous créer
la communauté légale puisque nous
n'avons aucune existence légale on a eu
des problèmes d'ailleurs pour louer la
salle parce qu'il est pas responsable
comme nous n'existons pas légalement
ensuite ensuite nous allons essayer de
nous allons lancer un appel au monde
entier en faisant venir des des athlètes
correspondre aux anneaux olympiques de
chaque continent n'ont lancé cet appel
du pavillon 2 du baron pierre de
coubertin pour avoir une action
internationale
on a appris ce soir que 80 % les
athlètes allemands étaient favorables
aux jeux de moscou
oui c'est une bonne nouvelle puisque le
parlement européen a s'est prononcé pour
le boycott je trouve que c'est une très
bonne nouvelle les prendrons pas moscou
nous dépendons salle uniquement les jeux
olympiques en général sir qu'on nous
considérons que jeux olympiques de
moscou sont nous ne sont qu'une étape et
que si cette étape n'a pas lieu il n'y
aura plus d'étapes ensuite les jeux
olympiques sont morts à partir du moment
où les prochains n'ont pas lieu
en attendant donc ceux d'hiver certaines
marques avait bien caché son jeu
troisième hier à l'issue de la première
manche du slalom spécial
il était bien embusqué pour doubler sur
le fil ses rivaux wendel et n ce qui fut
fait sans difficulté qu'un le roi
incontesté du slalom géant
je trace et robin wright penn il a fait
dans la deuxième manche une véritable
démonstration et remportez somme toute
facilement le titre olympique
sûr de lui très souple les skis bien à
plat se relançant parfaitement sur
chaque porte n'a commis aucune faute 3e
à 32 centièmes de wendel à l'issue de la
première manche il a repris la bagatelle
d'une secondes et sept centièmes aux
coureurs du liechtenstein en scène au
précieux est troisième à une seconde et
77 500 lits à 91 points alors qu'il
n'avait que 19 ans sans doute surpris
par l'ambiance il n'avait obtenu qu'une
médaille de bronze en géant depuis il a
remporté trois coupes du monde deux
titres de champion du monde en géant 1
spécial il me manquait le titre
olympique c'est depuis aujourd'hui sauce
fête sa victoire dans le géant de ces
jeux olympiques et la 15e victoire
consécutive obtenue dans cette
spécialité 23 ans in-game astana est
incontestablement le meilleur skieur de
sa génération
c'est somme toute très décontracté qu'il
a regardé descendre son dauphin andreas
denzel très certainement le score le
plus complet que tel il apporte sa
deuxième médaille d'argent au
liechtenstein et la deuxième médaille
d'argent la famille wendel puisque sa
soeur a terminé derrière annemarie
mother l'abaissant n'attendait davantage
wenzel en slalom c'est dire qu'il sera
l'un des favoris vendredi prochain dans
une pure sans doute plus ouvert
qu'aujourd'hui mais après annemarie
moser avec lacie vient des kings et
martèle marc de sacré un bien beau
champion olympique
un joli coup de chapeau aussi à la
mecque
eric heiden qui est en voie de gagner
son pari c'est vous savez un patineur de
vitesse il voulait emporter les cinq
épreuves des jeux olympiques
il en a déjà trois à son actif le 500 m
le 5000 m est ici le 1000 m emporté avec
une seconde et demie d'avancé sur l'as
canadien boucher
il ne lui reste plus que deux médailles
d'or à obtenir pour réussir cette
manière de grand chelem
le quinze 100 m et le 10000 m l'arrivée
donc de l'amérique un musée du cinéma
depuis aujourd'hui le musée henri
langlois qui méritait bien de figurer au
frontispice de ce temple du septième art
c'est un reportage que vous propose
maintenant france roche
le 22 mai 1895 les frères lumière montré
au grand café à leur premier public ce
film qu'il avait tourné à la sortie de
leur usine
85 ans de cinéma plus tard monsieur
lecard ministre de la culture l'a vu
hier au musée du cinéma harry langlois
tout remis à neuf et ouvert au public
fait que l'année dernière il ya eu 177
millions de français qui ont été au
cinéma ça veut dire que à côté d'autres
formes d'expression le cinéma reste très
vivant très actif et coq au vin et
patrimoine il faut lui sont mis en
valeur
parmi les 5000 objets réunis en 35 ans
par henri langlois
la première caméra inventé par un
français en 1874 le fusil photographique
des marais des manuscrits de méliès à
fellini et photos des costumes des
décors assez moules vides des idées des
patients s'adjoindront grâce à l'aide de
l'état 4 millions par an d'autres
reliques
est-ce qu'on arrivera à recueillir comme
ici le maillot de bain d'esther williams
est ce pas là la tunique de rudolf
valentino la capd ivan mosjoukine et
cetera
ça c'était la magie d'henri langlois il
faut pas oublier que ce henri langlois
je ne sais pas si on aurait pu faire
quel est l'objet qu'elle aime
document qui vous a le plus intéressé à
la cinémathèque il en doit écouter
il ya quelque chose qui était né
naturellement fascinant qui est le
premier dessin animé qui est présenté
dans une voûte continue que donc le
public verra qui est tout simplement un
oiseau blanc qui volent sur un fond bleu
et le premier dessin animé de l'histoire
est d'ailleurs presque l'un des premiers
mouvements animé de l'histoire du cinéma
on peut découvrir d'autres première au
musée du cinéma depuis l'image de la
chambre noire inventé au xviiie siècle à
naples par des latences de ces machines
les petits oiseaux et les grands sont
sortis premiers trucages premiers films
d'arts premiers dessins animés et muskol
premier film en couleur premièr plan
premier suspense première tarte à la
crème première qui nomme girls premier
indien dans les petits enfants des farl
encore sur nos écrans
sur quatre temps celui de la peur
le feu
du rire
réelle ou de l'imaginaire le cinéma
congi glamour grâce à ses marionnettes
les stars catalogue de tous les désirs
le cinéma est une caverne où elle
alibaba dessiné par méliès cacherait un
siècle de rêve le temps maintenant
encore assez doux un peu moins qu'hier
quand même vous voyez il a fait 13
degrés à la rochelle les 6 degrés
seulement à strasbourg demain la météo
prévoit des nuages sur toutes les côtes
de l'ouest et du nord puis des
éclaircies sur la bretagne sur le
languedoc-roussillon haletant qui
deviendra très nuageux avec quelques
pluies parfois orageuses ailleurs des
brouillards givrants dans le nord-est et
le centre mais ensuite un temps assez
ensoleillé
dernier rendez-vous avec l'actualité ce
soir vers 23h30 paul amar après les
haussiers d'écran demain à 12h40
cinquantaine de midi avec comme metteur
en page un homme qui parle peu mais que
nous ferons parler eric tabarly
et puis demain si vous voulez bien ce
même journal de 20h avec la même équipe
à bientôt à demain j'espère en tout cas
bonne soirée